how did i get that job so so like
they don't hire people she was right
right like she wasn't wrong they don't
hire people without a college degree
which is terrible by the way because you
learn nothing at college the only thing
you learn in college is to have contempt
for the working class like deaf contempt
for people who don't have a college
degree so this is not a pro-college
argument this is like an anti-morgan
stanley argument that they insist that
people have this credential just for
their own prestige right it has nothing
to do with what you learn there but
anyway setting that inside it's their
choice they're right a lot of companies
don't implement that rule though it's
changed since this channel slowly
changes especially the big tech company
yeah totally tech is is good on this
front only this month anyway
cut that clip up real quick yeah
supported that happened um but um
so the the i don't have to have an
explanation for i mean i assume it has
something to do with your charisma and
the force of your personality and like
something unique that that was a that
was first conveyed through that cover
letter and then in interviews which i
think you know like i think you're being
a little bit like i disagree consciously
naive but because because the fact that
you're the only one who did it right
like the fact that you're the only one
who managed to do it i disagree i'm not
the only one that did it
my friend steve avedyan was another 1.8
gpa guy he came out he was you know
doing nothing he was helping out as that
as a truck driver him and his buddy
alfred decide to go being truck drivers
you tell me who's a truck driver they
were nobodies like oh they're gonna make
it in business no four year no two year
no nothing they're running a 300 million
dollar transportation business today
so i can i can go on all of these
stories
to say hey
let's keep feeling sorry for everybody
there's a big difference between
sympathy empathy and trying to rise up
now you know i agree with you i don't
want to come off as someone who's like
oh you should all feel sorry i don't
want to come off that way okay we're on
the same page there they don't feel that
way like they're proud of their work
they feel that it is
i think i think what they're doing is
also very is something they should be
proud of okay so that i guess that would
be my next question would be like like
someone has to be the person who is the
custodial staff right who's not going to
make it big right someone has to be the
person who is stalking the shelves at
the supermarket right we all rely on the
label it's a choice of of of p but we we
need them we need
no one's judging them right but i'm
saying so because we need them
we should be invested in those jobs
granting dignity and a living wage
because we need them to not be and we do
in this job or in this job and we do
right so but i'm but like but from their
point of view they're struggling oh yeah
and they are struggling and i and by the
way i i i what's the answer to that yeah
but but why don't we see why are they
struggling
because you can't live on 15 an hour in
new york city but but why are they
struggling though why are they
struggling though is it just is your
argument only they can't make it on 50
bucks an hour the housing market okay
okay so why do we have that rh is a big
part of it actually you talk about this
a lot okay so so okay so but why are
let's actually dissect oh yeah okay why
why why
i'm gonna write it down i'm gonna write
notes so tell me why they're struggling
i'm gonna take notes i'll be the student
insulate
guys i hope you understand like
this is why the audience likes these
types of conversations i love it and
this is why i have so much respect for
you
that you you don't you go anywhere and
talk to anybody and you love them
by the way i have a very serious
question for you i know i'm going to
wait
up here stay there
here so why are they here
um why why are they watching
yeah why are they struggling so so um
there's sort of three tiers of people in
let's say what we would call labor the
working class right the top tier is not
struggling at all cops electricians
plumbers like there's a lot of dignity
in those jobs right now they're well
paid they make a living wage and a lot
of them are able to afford their own
homes especially if they live in red
states where housing is not the same as
it is are you talking about the working
class blue collar jobs here if you will
okay so that's the upper echelon which
degree aren't rich upper echelon of
working classes
yeah a lot of government employees
exactly um yeah exactly yeah okay um
then you have the middle tier who are
people who
like they are they're not poor
and i wouldn't even say they're
struggling they're not like lying awake
at night how am i gonna pay for this or
that although right now it's very
difficult because of inflation but
that's a very it's a unique situation
right now their biggest struggle is they
do not have access to the american dream
because they cannot they're not gonna be
homeowners in their lifetime and we know
that owning a home is how you transfer
that wealth to the next generation right
what's sort of a classic standard for
like how we what we call like middle
class life right and who are these
people what type of job a lot of
truckers are in this position this is
people who are making between 40 and 60
65 you know um what retail truck drivers
one one lower i would say so yeah so so
truckers you know um um people who are
you know let's say in um you know the
trades often you know if they're not
maybe editors and uh
and graphic designer types
um a lot of people in the bottom layer
of the tech industry you know um these
are people who are making like i said
between 40 and 60 if you're making 60
and you're living in new york you'll
never own a home right if you're making
40 and you're living here would probably
be difficult as well and then you've got
that bottom tier of people who we
all of these people are people whose
whose labor we rely on to exist right
like we rely on them not deciding to
become an entrepreneur and make a
million dollars so that they no longer
have to do these jobs just as a society
we rely on them right right who are
these bottom rungs
are people who are in retail people who
are cashiers
3.5 million people are our cashiers you
know three million retail associates in
america fast food workers right now it
happens to be that even though the
federal minimum wage is seven twenty
five an hour and then 759 an hour most
of these people now are making
between 12 and 15. the problem is is
that in many of the places
that is not a living wage that is
basically poverty wages you know so
where i live i live in brooklyn i
actually don't live in like one of the
most expensive neighborhoods i live in
an immigrant neighborhood it's sort of
more reasonable
but still the guy who delivers my amazon
packages will never would never dream of
owning yeah but are these people
immigrants what is there any data of who
these people are
who is like this lower third it's a lot
are they
are they just naturally born americans
or just strive to be a mcdonald's worker
i doubt it the question of which tier
you end up in is very interesting
what it seems to me like and this is
something pat you've brought up on your
show is that one of the
number one predictors of whether you end
up in the bottom
is whether you come from a single mother
family and whether you are a single
mother or a single parent because we
know that marriage is very tightly
correlated with higher earnings and
economists don't know exactly why that
is but it's quite hard to be poor if
you're married i mean that's just a
weird phenomenon of american life that
nobody wants to talk about you're saying
it's hard to be poor if you're married
married men
let me give you a statistic okay because
this is really this blew my mind
so the median income is around forty
four thousand dollars a year right
um the median income for a black male
head of household who's who's not
married is 33 000 a year
the median income for a black male head
of household who's married is 93 000 a
year which is not a sneak nobody who's
making that is struggling you know
that's a person who's living a middle
class life so the the answers are not oh
you should feel sorry for these people
right the question is how do we get more
people from the bottom into the higher
rungs but again like i said like some of
that labor
right
fast food workers right
we rely on that we rely on there being
people to but but stay there though so
so let me ask you a question the
population today is what 7.9 billion
yeah okay
uh how long did it take us to double
that population
60 years 60 years ago we were at 3.6
billion
how long did it take us to double that
3.6 billion to 1.8 billion
40 50 years prior to that we have 1.8
billion i can co keep going back and
back and write okay
the idea
of a person staying where they're at
everything in life is about graduating
okay
what's graduating
one should not stay in a position
forever without graduating to the next
level we should grow and we should
create an environment where people are
developing and increasing the level of
contribution to society
that's me i worked at burger king i
wanted to be a cashier they never made
me a cashier i worked as a chef i was a
cook i made waffles
burger king i bragged about it i was a
chef they gave me a medium shirt and i
was six one you could see my lower back
my guys were coming to laugh at me no
joke my friends know exactly what i'm
talking about can i just say you are
amazing like you're so cool what you've
been through and like what you've
achieved like it's very cool like your
story is very inspiring i appreciate
that thank you but also for me
everything that's inspiring to me
i look at guys like
what life he lived and how he became who
he is today from sleeping on the couch
as a comedian to having made it in the
insurance business and nothing in his
background says about good good for him
i see him from going from military to
them becoming a comedian next thing you
know he's on deaf comedy jam and he made
it but by the way you know a lot of us
have that story of going from nothing to
making it making it doesn't mean being a
billionaire so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]